best movie on there is the 40 year old
yeah absolutely
i think so honestly i think i think
i've out of because i wanted to put a
comedy movie on i was thinking what
comedy movie can i
infinitely rewatch you've got like three
on yeah you've got scott piller and
versus the world
space jam
yeah it's okay it is definitely a it's
it's a comedy movie but it's not just
girl comedy in there because
i love like i mean like i was forty year
old virgin it's great story of a man
you know coming to losers of course it's
a great coming-of-age story
yeah and i was thinking like what
because i feel like recently comedy
movies have kind of just
died i don't know if that's the thing
what's what's well i mean
you know it's like it's like it's like
they're like the [ __ ] will ferrell
movies in uh
all the modern adam sandler films uncut
gems
i've just [ __ ] made it yeah that's
literally only it
yeah but also the adam satellite movies
do extremely well on netflix
and really some of the most watched
things on netflix the ones that they
bought off
i think i've seen an arab salem movie
since because they're all so mediocre
yeah and the only one that he he was
amazing in which was uncut gems is
absolutely [ __ ] amazing
yeah um wasn't even his movie he was
some he was just he's the main actor
yeah i've heard is that a comedy movie
or is that just a movie
it's like a pretty pretty uh brutal
movie looking really [ __ ] good though
yeah
all i've seen from that is the clip when
he goes oh my god i'm gonna come
that's pretty much all i've seen without
moving i'm just like
what is going on adam sandler what is
happening right now
please watch it if you haven't it's i
think it's his best role yeah
but yeah 40 year old virgin is like to
me the
infinitely rewatchable comedy movie for
me that used to play on british
television
i think like once a [ __ ] week no
that's why i've watched it so many times
everyone in the uk has watched it
because you used to play on british like
all the [ __ ] time this is also one of
those movies that never leaves the
airplane
like exactly always playing like if you
look up movies on an airplane
like the all the classics john right
it's always interesting so many famous
scenes in that movie like the [ __ ]
tit scene where they talk about feeling
a boob oh yeah it's like a sandbag
and the [ __ ] waxing scene as well
it's iconic it's iconic and i feel like
this gets
talked about less than maybe like at
least at least when it first came out
because
the iconic was that one of his like most
famous like is that one of the roles
that i blew him up
this was when i first started first
started to know steve carell
because i didn't know about him before
because i think before that the only
thing i've seen him
in was like bruce or micey yeah but he
had like one
iconic scene he wasn't the main
character he wasn't the main character i
mean it was jim carrey yeah
um but i feel like this was his first
movie where i was just like
damn this guy is funny this is a funny
[ __ ] movie yeah probably
but i remember back when this came out
um the iconic
comedy movie when this first came out
was super bad
classic everyone was like two thousands
humor like that was yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah everyone tp
humor and everyone was quoting superbad
and i was
like i've kind of i kind of think the
four-year-old virgin's funnier
that was just hushes me back then i
thought super bad was funny for like
two months no no when you're in high
school super bad is like the funniest
[ __ ]
oh yeah it's like it's like you're just
going through it but like when you've
heard of like the
the you know one thousandth mclovin joke
you're just like all right yeah i get it
i get it it's kind of same with borat
right yeah
actually it's so fun um like uh sydney
had never seen borat before
right so i uh so she watched more app
for the first time
in 2021 about like about like a month
ago okay
and like like me someone who's like been
quoted more at throughout my entire high
school yeah it's been quoted to death
right um i i i you know it's hard to
find it funny anymore because it's just
been like
everyone's just it's so ingrained it's
so ingrains that i just
ceased to find it funny anymore she
still found it [ __ ] hilarious oh it's
so
funny it's legitimately hilarious like
when i watch that movie all i think is
like god damn he's such a
[ __ ] amazing actor yeah he is there's
app there's no movie that even comes
close to like that kind of experience
he does it's crazy admittedly you know
like i i could probably quote most of
that movie but i'd be lying if i said
every time i heard boracay
my life like
oh [ __ ] this was funny at the point i
forgot that this was legitimately funny
yeah yeah yeah yeah
the genius of [ __ ] bar it like made
you on a surface level you think that oh
this is just he he funny movie yeah yeah
but it was really just a really [ __ ]
intelligent way of showing how racist
america
yeah exactly and that's how good and the
best part was is that
those people were the ones quoting it
yeah it came out exactly
but it's like a genius way of showing it
in a way that like he made a
he showed like how like i guess there
was like racist problems in america
before it was like you know talked about
wildly today yeah
and still it was massively marketed
towards the audience and i
didn't even know that that's what he was
poking fun at well that's what well
that's what i [ __ ] loved about ali g
back in the day
oh my god that's a name i haven't heard
instead like that is a movie as well
yeah like that oh my god like the first
time i watched that like i thought
everything was scripted and like a lot
of it is but like
some of the interview scenes stuff like
that like it's all non-scripted i'm like
how the [ __ ] does he do that he's just a
genius like being able to turn a
situation
and like make them look stupid without
having to like
make them think that he's playing a
character yeah yeah he's so good at that
yeah
like he yeah he is actually like like a
social genius because he knows how to
work people so well yeah and the thing
is like
i i just he gets so invested in this
character so
it's it's actually insane like nightmare
being married to him
like which character are you tonight
honey like because i remember
like re-watching borah with sydney there
was this one scene where he gets drunk
with a bunch of american frat boys and
at first i was like there's no way this
is real this must be scripted
right and so we looked into it and uh
it's totally real to the point got drunk
with them yeah
to the point where he got like blackout
drunk with them and just was able to
stay in character this entire [ __ ]
time
that's [ __ ] dedication man it's
insane like so baked i think by the time
he goes to do these characters it's so
[ __ ] baked in his head yeah
he's this character that he doesn't even
think i i oh i'm doing an act he's just
yeah he just that's just him
he just thinks this is me it's just
insane i don't know it's such an insane
maybe you should have put more out yeah
i i didn't put bart on my i wish i did
now because i just like the whole i
find it all so fascinating and like what
is america is so [ __ ] funny as well
like
oh he's just so funny yeah he's very
very good absolutely [ __ ] genius